in the opening scene a medieval looking
man is traveling along the road minding
his own business when suddenly a giant
demon monkey appears in front of him the
man is then ruthlessly attacked and sent
flying like a ragdoll as the Demonic
Beast appears to be just too powerful I
hate it when that happens following this
we are given a brief introduction of the
man he is Sun Wukong an arrogant guy who
had created a Ruckus In The Heavenly
Palace hundreds of years ago it is
revealed that he had broken through the
sky and caused chaos chaos which
ultimately led to him being expelled
from the Heavenly Palace now he has
fallen to the Earth and is imprisoned
but his whereabouts are unknown moving
on to the present we are introduced to
ye a young girl who is on a mission to
find sun Wu Kong she hopes to locate him
so that she can seek his help in
reaching the sky Palace turns out Yi
wants to report her tragic fate of
losing her parents who were killed by
long Tai Zee the god of Dragon one day
he arrives at the supposed location
where Wukong is imprisoned but she
encounters evil demons who try to
capture her in an attempt to escape Yi
starts running but the surface tears
apart and she falls into it with this
the demons are about to capture the
little girl but suddenly they hear a
familiar voice it is none other than Wu
Kong the only problem is that he is
bound by shackles so the demons
completely ignore him but just then ye
accidentally touches a button that
releases Wukong from his imprisonment
now free he quickly defeats all the bad
guys using his flashy moves before
fleeing the place with ye in the
following scene we see Tai Z gazing upon
his old Palace which has been destroyed
by the mighty woo Kong he is still
devastated by the incident at the same
time a maid enters with his drink and
starts making fun of the old Palace this
infuriates taizi so much that he stabs
the poor maid to death in a fit of rage
after a while taizi receives word that
Wukong has been freed and is preparing
to engage in a fierce battle with him
and he's a little tougher than that maid
meanwhile Wukong wakes the little girl
up from her stupor and as soon as she
sees him she she hugs them tightly but
ye is unsure of how to address Wukong as
she is confused about whether he is a
demon or an animal to clarify her
confusion Wukong confirms that he is in
fact The Monkey King you're just a
monkey he then pleads with him to help
her reach the Heavenly Palace as she
seeks to report the god of dragon for
the Grievous mistake of having killed
her parents Wukong doesn't say yes but
he decides to take her to his old home
so they embark on their Journey
traversing through various terrain until
they come upon a village of demons that
appears to be deserted upon closer
inspection they realize that the demons
are being mercilessly Shackled and
depressed by a tyrannical ruling god
named Shang day as a result of their
past Rebellion Against The Gods the
demons are now being slaughtered one
after the other in an act of gruesome
punishment appalled by the sight Wukong
takes it upon himself to fight against
shangdi and put an end to his reign of
terror however before he can make a move
Wukong is suddenly tapped on the
shoulder from behind by his own brother
Liu who knocks him out cold a few hours
later Wukong wakes up to find himself in
Liu's Abode little Yi is also there
enjoying some food Leo admits that he
knocked Wukong unconscious to save him
from getting killed as he knows his
brother is currently powerless without
his Golden Stick which is trapped within
the sea Kingdom Liu tries to discourage
Wukong from fighting against the God as
he had previously made a grave Mistake
by rebelling in the Heavenly Palace just
to prove his superiority although
wukong's intentions were to prevent his
brothers from being underestimated his
actions had led to the death of many of
them Leah warns him not to repeat the
same mistake but Wukong disregards his
advice with the two at loggerheads
Wukong decides to leave the place
however he is halted by his
sister-in-law who arrives with several
demon armies unwilling to back down
Wukong engages in a fierce battle with
all of them and eventually emerges
Victorious but then Liu arrives and the
two brothers start Going Hammer and
tongs at each other without his Golden
Stick Wukong appears to be fragile and
Liu takes advantage of this fortunately
before anyone gets hurt Yi intervenes
and manages to run away with Wukong
elsewhere long Tai Z is approached by a
god named muzan who presents him with a
weapon that has been crafted by the
devil the weapon is said to possess
dangerous abilities that allow the user
to control individuals affected by its
magic power muzon gives taizi the weapon
in order to stop Wu Kong from causing
chaos as he did before the gods fear
that Wukong May repeat his past actions
hence why they are concerned about his
freedom however muzon warns taizi not to
use the weapon for personal gain and
just take Wukong captive as the decision
lies with the Heavenly Palace despite
this taizi refuses to cooperate and
kills muzan on the spot claiming that he
does not need anyone's help to capture
Wukong he took the weapon though he then
orders his men to dispose of muzon's
body and falsely reports that Wukong is
the one responsible for the God's death
it is evident that taizi did this on
purpose to lure the gods into pursuing
Wukong elsewhere after a tiring Journey
Wukong finally arrives at his old home
where he seeks to retrieve his Golden
Stick at first he encounters his pet a
giant gorilla and attempts to greet
however the Beast doesn't recognize
Wukong due to years of separation and
instead becomes aggressive fortunately
he manages to calm him down using a
banana oh banana after that the two
reached the place where the Golden Stick
is being kept Wukong uses all his might
to retrieve it but he is unable to make
it budge from its place a short while
later a serpent General appears to
prevent Wukong from taking his Golden
Stick on taizi's order the two engage in
a fierce battle with Wukong at a
disadvantage due to the absence of his
trusted weapon he struggles to fend off
the Serpent's attacks and is soon backed
into a corner in a moment of desperation
the serpent accidentally injures Yi
causing her Holy Blood to flow onto the
Golden Stick suddenly the weapon comes
alive and glows with a powerful Aura
ultimately releasing from the seal this
energizes Wukong and after wielding his
stick he effortlessly defeats the
serpent General and sends his ass
backing after the victory wukong's
Spirits are lifted so he promises ye to
take her to the Heavenly Palace in the
next scene we witness the cruel Shang
day slaughtering the defenseless demons
until it's the turn of a child Liu who
is also there tries to stop the
heartless God by offering him some money
but to no avail instead shangdae demands
the sacrifice of another demon in place
of the child Liu stares at his friends
in shock and when no one steps up he
decides to sacrifice himself the cruel
God then prepares to execute him when
suddenly Wukong appears out of nowhere
and starts fighting against the Bad Guys
reinvigorated by his magical stick he
takes down everyone and almost manages
to kill shangdae believe stops him from
doing so the latter reasons that they
are not heartless so they should show
Mercy to their enemies after the
encounter the demons start chanting for
Wukong and even agree to help him on his
journey to the Heavenly Palace however
Liu remains obstinate and refuses to
support his brother prompting Wukong to
leave with the other demons meanwhile
the serpent General reports to taizi
about his unsuccessful attempt to stop
Wukong from retrieving his Golden Stick
he also discloses the important
information that a little girl girl's
blood unsealed the Golden Stick taizi is
enraged by this news so he decides to
have the girl arrested believing that
her blood can activate the magic weapon
provided to him too by muzan some time
later Wukong and his group of demons
continue their journey to fight against
cruel rulers in different Villages their
battle is successful and they managed to
overpower the oppressors with ease
following this Triumph they decide to
celebrate with a small party however
unbeknownst to them the serpent General
sneaks into their Gathering by
disguising himself as one of wukong's
demon Army later that night while Wukong
and Yi are spending some time together
the little girl reveals that she has led
a lonely life since her parents were
killed by Tai Z Wukong tries to comfort
her by reassuring her that he will take
her to the Heavenly Palace soon the next
day Wukong and his army successfully
capture shangdae although Wukong wants
to execute him ye who is fed up with the
violence thinks otherwise she frees the
cruel God without thinking twice this
decision leads to an argument between
Wukong and Yi causing her to leave anger
as she walks away the serpent General
seizes the opportunity and abducts her
shortly after they arrive at taizi's
place the latter immediately gets to
action and uses her blood to activate
his dangerous magic weapon he then tests
the weapon on one of his soldiers by
controlling his mind shockingly the poor
guy commits the unthinkable now with the
confirmation that the weapon Works taizi
plans to destroy wukong's reputation so
without any further Ado he takes over
wukong's body and forces him to fight
against his own Army despite wukong's
attempts to resist the magic is too
powerful and he is unable to regain
control of his own body as a result
taizi even makes Wukong kill his own
giant pet the experience leaves Wukong
heartbroken and shattered as he is
unable to prevent his own body from
carrying out these atrocities after a
short while the magic controlling
wukong's body dissipates leaving him
devastated and filled with regret taizi
takes advantage of the opportunity and
snatches wukong's Golden Stick using it
as a bargaining ship to spare his life
however taizi soon backstabs just as he
is about to execute Wukong Liu comes to
the rescue and destroys his weapon the
movie then shifts to the scene where
Wukong wakes up from a terrible
nightmare filled with desperation and
uncertainty he turns to his brother for
help but leeu is unable to assist him as
the other demons view Wukong as a
traitor they are even hunting for him
because of the atrocities he committed
the future looks bleak for Wukong as he
is left with nothing but his own will to
persevere following the devastating
events Wukong is now forced to live his
life in isolation full of disappointment
and yearning for Yee's companionship he
walks around the town with a heavy heart
hiding his identity from everyone who
now sees him as a traitor one day while
wandering around town he bumps into
Shang day who is also upset because
everyone has disowned him so with
nothing to lose he gives up he's
whereabouts this information rekindles
wukong's hope and determination to
rescue her so he sets out on yet another
Journey but since he doesn't have his
favorite weapon he simply carries an
ordinary stack back at the palace the
serpent General changes his heart and
decides decides to help ye because he
realizes how ruthless and unjust taizi's
actions are and he cannot bear to see an
innocent girl suffer however before he
can execute his plan taizi catches him
and throws him into prison as well while
in captivity the serpent General reveals
to ye the reason why he despises Wukong
according to him the chaos and
destruction caused by Wukong in the past
affected all the demons including
himself after a while Wukong finally
reaches the Palace of the Dragon God and
charges at him with his ordinary stick
taizi remains unimpressed and unfazed by
his arrival knowing that Wukong is
powerless without his Golden Stick
nevertheless our protagonist fights with
all his might using the meager weapons
that he has despite his best efforts
taizi gains the upper hands and Corners
Wukong with his Trident intending to
strike the final blow but right then the
serpent General reappears having freed
himself and ye using his magic following
this Wukong and the serpent General team
up to confront taizi in a fierce battle
but despite even their combined efforts
they cannot defeat the God and
unfortunately in the midst of the fight
kaizi hurls his Trident towards ye
killing her in front of Wukong causing
him immeasurable grief and despair
kaizi's intention is to make Wukong
experience the pain of losing someone
dear to him however Yi's death has an
unexpected outcome her Holy Blood mixes
with wukong's soul turning him into an
invincible figure the super The Monkey
King after the complete transformation
wukong's anger takes over causing the
demons to recognize that The Monkey King
is returned with a Vengeance utilizing
his extraordinary strength Wukong
retrieves his Golden Stick and enlarges
it to an enormous size piercing the sky
and transporting him to the Heavenly
palace here he intends to report Yee's
death and Avenge the god of dragon's
actions in an intense battle Wukong then
fights taizi and is able to hold his own
even when the latter transforms into his
Dragon Avatar he relentlessly beats the
evil God and defeats him brutally
however as Wukong is about to kill taizi
he remembers the promise he made to ye
to not take any lives as a result he
decides to spare taizi's life that was
almost certainly a mistake shortly after
Leo and the serpent General arrived to
support Wukong and kill taizi but he
orders them to stop wukong's appearance
in the Heavenly Palace is not meant to
cause chaos but rather to make amends
and avoid any further disturbances after
a while Lord Buddha appears in front of
Wukong he acknowledges that taizi had
gone beyond the limits and wukong's
actions were Justified he also expresses
his pride in Wukong who has changed
himself and does not seek commotion any
longer Lord Buddha advises him to
forgive ye's departure as her presence
in the world was to eliminate wukong's
selfish nature and help him become a
better person hearing this Wukong
promises to abandon his arrogance and
support his demon comrades in carrying
out rightful Deeds finally ye Spirit
ascends into the sky completing wukong's
mission in the last scene Wukong is seen
recovering his strength at Mount Fuji
hundreds of years later a Monk falls
into the pit and Wukong recognized him
as The Reincarnation of the God of
Dragons unaware of wukong's true
identity the monk inquires whether he is
a demon animal or human these words
reignite wukong's ambition to show the
world that he is in fact the great
Monkey King I Am The Prince of all
monkeys
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching